bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de thomasz hop hop c'est
les du xviie
siècle il est principalement connu pour
son oeuvre politique le léviathan
d'ailleurs up est considérée après
machiavel comme le fondateur de la
philosophie politique moderne et il
exercera une grande influence sur sa
postérité obs était un contemporain de
descartes des cartes d'ailleurs avec
lequel il était en conflit ouvert sur la
question métaphysique de la substance
spirituelle up ne croyait pas dans
l'existence d'une substance spirituelle
puisque en français en anglais et ce
prix ne désigne pas exactement la même
chose mind en anglais ne recouvre pas le
sens du mot esprits en france est
d'ailleurs en faisant mes recherches
pour préparer cette vidéo je suis tombé
sur quelques extraits de la polémique
qu'il a eu avec des cartes et je
trouvais amusant que vous en lire un
petit extrait parce que ça montre qu'au
xviie siècle déjà le clash ça existait
et le clash avait beaucoup plus
d'élégance qu'il n'en a aujourd'hui
et donc ça donne cette réponse à des
cartes par obs je cite je ne crois pas
devoir jamais plus répondre à ce que
vous me pourriez envoyé de cet homme que
je pense devoir mépriser à l'extrême et
je ne me laisse nullement flatté par les
louanges que vous me demandez qu'il me
donne car je connais qu'il n'en a plus
que pour mieux faire croire qu'il a
raison en ce sens où il me reprend et me
calomnie donc au delà de l'aspect
anecdotique l'amusant de cette polémique
ce qui compte c'est de comprendre que le
désaccord entre hop c'est des cartes
étaient révélateurs d'une divergence
dans la conception du monde entre deux
traditions philosophiques d'un côté la
tradition continental et notamment la
tradition française et d'un autre côté
la tradition anglo saxonne puisque là où
la philosophie française se réclament du
rationalisme c'est à dire le privilège
accordé à la raison à l'esprit la
tradition anglo saxonne
elle va se caractériser par son
empirisme c'est à dire le primat du
corps de la sensation et de la matière
donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire bien ça
veut dire que la tradition philosophique
anglo saxon va plutôt privilégier les
connaissances acquises par l'observation
des faits par la méthode expérimentale
cessa l'empirisme c'est l'idée que toute
connaissance doit être issu de la
perception et donc on va avoir dans la
philosophie de obs
cet attachement au réalisme voire au
pragmatisme et c'est ce réalisme qui va
nous permettre de comprendre la
conception politique de obs
pour oxz ce qui va importer pour
construire sa conception politique pour
construire sa théorie de l'état c'est
d'abord de comprendre la nature de
l'homme on ne peut pas construire une
théorie de l'état
si on n'a pas d'abord une connaissance
de ce qu'est la nature humaine ce qui
est plutôt logique puisque une théorie
politique
son objet c'est la société autrement dit
ce sont les interactions humaines et
donc pour savoir quel est le meilleur
modèle pour régir les comportements au
sein de la société
il est nécessaire de savoir comment les
hommes se comportent et donc à cette
question qu'est ce que la nature humaine
offs à une réponse et sa réponse est de
dire que l'homme est par nature égoïste
violent et calculateur pour up
l'homme n'est pas naturellement
bienveillant altruiste ou pacifique
il est d'abord hostile et agressif
envers ses semblables et d'ailleurs pour
lui c'est sa l'origine de l'état
politique de l'état civil qui s'opposent
à l'état de nature
l'état politique c'est le moyen de
neutraliser l'égoïsme et la violence des
hommes
si on laisse les hommes vivre sans loi
les hommes vont se livrer à la violence
les uns contre les autres
donc c'est cette vision qui est exposé
dans le léviathan d'ailleurs entre
parenthèses le léviathan c'était le nom
d'un monstre marin biblique c'est un
monstre qui apparaît dans les psaumes
notamment à la fois dragon serpents et
crocodiles
imaginez le tableau est une citation
nous dit à propos du léviathan que sur
terre nul n'est son maître sur terre nul
n'est son maître et donc ça c'est
l'analogique europe choisie pour décrire
l'état parce que l'état c'est la plus
puissante des entités terrestre la plus
puissante des entités qui doit inspirer
la crainte et le respect des hommes donc
vous noterez bien sur terre nul n'est
son maître c'est très important de le
signaler
parce qu'autrefois jusqu'au 16e siècle
avec machiavel l'état tiré sa puissance
et sa légitimité de dieu
alors bon dieu interprété par les hommes
mais de pouvoir est exercé au nom de
dieu au nom des préceptes divins et
c'est parce que l'état était un
représentant de dieu sur terre que les
citoyens devaient lui obéir
l'état s'était l'intermédiaire entre
dieu et les hommes et les lois politique
était la transfiguration des lois
divines
il y avait toujours ce lien
indissociable entre politique et
religion
avec machiavel et plus tard avec cox on
va assister à une rupture du lien entre
politique et religieux et donc les
hommes ne devront plus craindre dieu les
hommes devront craindre l'état et
devront craindre la plus puissante des
entités terrestre et ça aussi vous allez
voir que ça va avoir une grande
importance pour comprendre la conception
politique d'europe
donc je disais pour oxz construire une
théorie politique de l'état s'est
d'abord comprendre comment se comportent
les hommes
n'oublions pas qu'au xviie siècle on est
en plein développement des sciences
expérimentales de la nature et que ce
modèle des sciences expérimentales va
beaucoup influencé les philosophes
politiques qui vont y voir l'occasion de
traiter la politique comme une science
pourrait dire que c'est la naissance
avant l'heure les sciences politiques
puisque obs va avoir une approche
physique des comportements humains et
des relations sociales et avoir une
approche physique des comportements
humains c'est comprendre quelles sont
les forces qui nous met en mouvement
quelles sont les forces qui nous font
agir c'est comprendre quelle est la loi
de la traction humaine qu'est ce qui
attire les hommes
qu'est ce qui les fait agir qu'est-ce
qui les mobilisent et donc pour offs ce
qui mobilise l'être humain c'est son
égoïsme c'est la considération et la
recherche de son intérêt privé donc
l'anthropologie de ops est basé sur
l'idée que l'homme est un être de désir
un être de passion un être qui est mû
par son conatus c'est à dire sa tendance
à persévérer dans son être et à déployer
sa puissance donc là on retrouve un
petit peu de siècle avant l'idée
nietzschéenne de la volonté de puissance
mais c'est une idée qu'on retrouve chez
beaucoup de philosophes du xviie et du
xviiie siècle à savoir l'idée que
l'homme est d'abord un être de désir est
que même si l'homme possède la raison ce
n'est pas sa raison qui le fait agir
ce n'est pas sa raison qui le met en
mouvement ce qui le met en mouvement
c'est une force qu'on appelle le désire
mais pour offs ça va encore un peu plus
loin parce que si l'homme n'était qu'un
être de désir
on pourrait considérer que ça ne
justifie pas forcément l'intervention de
l'état pour gérer les comportements
humains après tout les désirent peuvent
très bien ce harmoniser les uns les
autres ils peuvent très bien s'accorder
sauf que pour
ce pas du tout les désirs humains ne
s'accorde pas et s'harmonisent pas ils
ne peuvent pas à s'harmoniser tout
simplement parce qu'ils portent les
hommes à la prédation le désir humain
chéops prend la forme de la prédation et
la prédation qu'est ce que c'est
étymologiquement c'est le fait de
prendre de prendre aux autres pour
satisfaire son intérêt et en même temps
ça suppose l'idée d'une 3 le prédateur
c'est celui qu'il a une proie à lapins
prédation vient de prada qui signifie la
proie
donc si l'être humain est un prédateur
qu'est ce qu'il va faire eh bien il va
vouloir prendre aux autres ce qui va
satisfaire son intérêt privé et son
intérêt ça veut dire quoi
mais ça veut dire tout ce qui contribue
à sa conservation
tout ce qui contribue à sa survie et à
la satisfaction de ses désirs
donc ce seront les ressources ce seront
les richesses ce sera le pouvoir parce
que les ressources les richesses et le
pouvoir permettent de sécuriser la
conservation donc de ce point de vue là
l'homme est un animal il lutte pour sa
survie
ils luttent pour son intérêt particulier
et pour obs il serait vain est illusoire
de vouloir qu'il en soit autrement
c'est à dire que à l'état de nature
l'état où la société et les lois
n'existent pas il n'y a pas de raison de
ne pas être un prédateur il n'y a pas de
raison parce qu'il n'ya pas de morale
parce qu'il n'ya pas de distinction
entre le bien et le mal
parce que le seul bien qui importe c'est
mon bien
c'est mon intérêt que je dois défendre
coûte que coûte
et si l'autre veut me prendre mon bien
il devra me tuer et comme je suis un
être programmé pour la survie comme je
possède un instinct de conservation et
bien j'ai tout intérêt à tuer l'autre
avant qu'il me tue
la devise de l'état de nature chéops
s'est tué avant d'être tué autrement dit
dans l'état de nature
le destin des hommes c'est la guerre
civile c'est la violence c'est la lutte
permanente pour la satisfaction des
passions individuelles
la paix est impossible dans l'état de
nature parce que la paix suppose une
distance vis-à-vis de nos intérêts ça
suppose de relâcher la tension mais sauf
que lorsque vous relâchez la tension
vous donnez à votre voisin l'opportunité
de prendre ce que vous avez donc vous ne
pouvez pas vous permettre de relâcher
l'attention devait être au contraire en
tension permanente et donc la paix n'est
pas possible
la paix n'est pas possible dans un
environnement où la rivalité et la loi
la seule règle qui existe dans l'état de
nature c'est la loi du plus fort c'est
le droit du plus fort ce qui d'ailleurs
est un oxymore puisque par définition le
droit est fait pour protéger le faible
déprédations du fort donc là encore on
retrouve la position nietzschéenne selon
laquelle les règles et notamment les
règles morales sont une invention des
faibles pour se protéger des forts et
d'ailleurs c'est vraiment un contresens
typiquement moderne de croire que la
règle est contraire à l'égalité alors
qu'au contraire la règle et protectrice
de l'égalité le libéralisme c'est la
dérégulation c'est la déréglementation
c'est à dire littéralement le retrait
des règles et c'est ça la volonté des
libéraux c'est la suppression des règles
c'est la suppression des règles qui font
obstacle au libre déploiement du marché
pourquoi et bien parce que les règles
elles ralentissent le bénéfice elles
ralentissent la croissance etc et
libéraux eux ce qu'ils veulent c'est la
croissance il pas l'égalité les libéraux
ils veulent un maximum de liberté pour
pouvoir augmenter la croissance
indéfiniment et c'est à ça que servent
les règles c'est à dire à protéger les
droits des plus faibles de ceux qui
subissent la prédation économique des
libéraux entre le fort et le faible
c'est la liberté qui opprime et la loi
qui libère et pour revenir à cette idée
de droit du plus fort eh bien on n'a pas
attendu
nietzsche lui-même obs pour défendre
cette conception des choses
on la trouve déjà dans l'antiquité
notamment chez un personnage du nom de
cali claisse cali claeys qui dans le
gorgias de platon nous dit que justement
le seul droit qui devrait prévaloir
c'est le droit du plus fort parce que
seul le droit du plus fort permet de
pousser les individus à l'excellence
si vous préférez la loi du plus fort
c'est ce qui fait que ce sont les
meilleurs qui survivent qu'une sorte de
darwinisme social avant l'heure là aussi
cette idée que le droit qui vient
limiter la puissance d'efforts à un
effet contre-productif donc là encore
vous lire la citation de qualité laisse
dans laquelle il expose cette vision ce
sont les faibles
la masse des gens qui établissent les
lois c'est donc en fonction d'eux mêmes
et de leurs intérêts personnels que les
faibles font les lois qu'ils attribuent
des louanges qu'il répartissent des
blâmes ils veulent faire peur aux hommes
plus fort qu'eux et qui peuvent leur
être supérieur c'est pour empêcher que
ces sommes ne leur soient supérieurs qui
disent qu'il est injuste d'avoir plus
que les autres et que l'injustice
consiste justement à vouloir avoir plus
car ce qui plaît aux faibles c'est
d'avoir l'air d'être égaux à de telles
sommes alors qu'ils leur sont inférieurs
il est évident selon moi que la justice
consiste en ce que le meilleur est plus
que le moins beau et le plus fort plus
que le moins fort partout il en est
ainsi c'est ce que la nature enseigne
chez toutes les espèces animales chez
toutes les races humaines et dans toutes
les cités alors je précise immédiatement
parce que certains d'entre vous
connaissent peut être l'oeuvre de hawx
les thèmes nature chéops ne prétend pas
décrire la condition des hommes avant
l'invention de l'état autrement dit
l'état de nature ne se veut pas une
réalité historique
ce n'est pas un état qui aurait
réellement existé vu d'ailleurs ça
semble même impossible puisque même si
l'état n'existe pas il existe malgré
tout des communautés à commencer par la
famille mais le fait est qu'on n'est pas
passé d'une situation où les hommes
vivaient de manière solitaire isolés les
uns des autres
un état social ça s'est pas passé comme
ça mais ce que veut faire offs
à travers cette fiction de l'état de
nature c'est mettre le doigt sur les
tendances fondamentales de l'être humain
c'est comme une sorte d'illustration
exacerbée des tendances humaine
primitive et la tendance primitive de
l'être humain c'est l'égoïsme et la
violence pour satisfaire cet égoïsme et
c'est ça qui nous fait arriver à la
célèbre citation de europe ce qui donne
son titre à cette vidéo l'homme est un
loup pour l'homme
alors quelques précisions sur cette
citation d'abord que ce n'est pas ops
qui est l'auteur de cette citation
puisqu'on la trouve dès l'antiquité
elle sera ensuite reprise par d'autres
auteurs après ans ensuite que cette
citation ne fait pas partie du léviathan
mais de la préface de son livre intitulé
des kiwis du citoyen et que cette
citation en réalité elle est tronquée
par
ce que juste avant obs dit aussi que
l'homme peut être un dieu pour l'homme
et lorsqu'il dit que l'homme est un loup
pour l'homme en réalité il veut parler
du comportement des états entre eux et
non pas directement du comportement
entre individus mais ça à la limite ce
sont des détails c'est pas très
important pour comprendre l'idée est
l'idée c'est que la réalité fondamentale
de l'être humain
ce sont ses passions ses passions ce que
freud appellera plus tard ses pulsions
puisque je le disais tout à l'heure
l'idée que l'homme est un être de désir
ne va pas s'arrêter au xviie siècle va
traverser les siècles jusqu'à freud et
la psychanalyse avec l'idée que l'homme
est d'abord animée par ses pulsions
c'est ça qui a fait dire aux
commentateurs d'europe ce qu'il faisait
preuve d'un pessimisme anthropologique
autrement dit un pessimisme sur la
nature humaine soit par exemple a
développé une conception totalement aux
antipodes en considérant lui que à
l'état de nature
l'homme est innocent et que c'est la
société qui le corrompt
au contraire pour offs c'est à l'état de
nature que l'homme est corrompue au sens
où il n'a aucune pitié
aucun scrupule où il se contente de
prendre ce qu'il veut indépendamment de
toute règle indépendamment de toute
compassion mais sauf que pour offs
il ne s'agit pas d'un pessimisme il
s'agit d'un réalisme et d'ailleurs il le
dit lui-même dans l'un de ses textes il
dit
quand vous voyez le nombre de crimes qui
sont commis malgré l'existence des lois
imaginez ce que cela donnerait si les
lois disparaissait quand vous voyez à
quel point les hommes sont capables
d'être des prédateurs malgré la menace
de la sanction et de la force publique
qu'est ce que cela donnerait si les lois
n'existaient pas alors évidemment vous
n'êtes pas obligé d'être d'accord avec
ce portrait que nous peuple de la nature
humaine
mais si vous n'êtes pas d'accord et que
vous pensez que l'être humain n'est pas
fondamentalement mauvais hop ça une
réponse pour vous et sa réponse c'est
que vous êtes des gros hypocrites
c'est ça la réponse de offs vous êtes d
au christ et pourquoi est ce que vous
êtes des hypocrites parce que vous
prétendez que l'homme n'est pas mauvais
mais dans votre comportement vous
agissez comme s'il était mauvais et donc
je vais vous lire un petit extrait du
chapitre xiii du livre1 du léviathan il
peut sembler étrange à celui qui n'a pas
bien peser ces choses que la nature
puisse ainsi dissocier les hommes et les
rendre enclins à s'attaquer et à se
détruire les uns les autres
c'est pourquoi peut-être incrédule à
l'égard de cette inférences tirer des
passions cet homme désire à l'avoir
confirmé par l'expérience aussi faisant
un retour sur lui-même alors que partant
en voyage ils s'arment et cherche à être
bien accompagné
callen se coucher il verrouille ses
portes que dans sa maison même il ferme
ses coffres à clé et tout cela sachant
qu'il existe des lois et des
fonctionnaires publics armée pour venger
tous les torts qui peuvent lui être fait
qu'ils se demandent quelle opinion et la
de ses compatriotes
quand il voyage armé de ses concitoyens
quand ils verrouillent ses portes de ses
enfants et de ses domestiques
quand il ferme ses coffres à clé donc ce
que nous dit hawks ici c'est qu'à chaque
fois que nous fermons notre porte à clé
nous prouvons que nous n'avons pas
confiance dans la nature humaine nous
prouvons que nous n'avons pas confiance
dans la bienveillance de l'homme nous
prouvons que nous considérons que
l'homme est un loup pour l'homme et donc
c'est là qu'on arrive à l'étape suivante
de l'analyse de obs puisque sa question
était de savoir comment la société at
elle été créée
pourquoi at elle été créée et sa réponse
c'est de dire que c'est la guerre de
tous contre tous qui va pousser les
hommes à se donner des lois alors par
quel mécanisme
et bien tout simplement par le mécanisme
de la peur la guerre de tous contre tous
fait que les hommes sont perpétuellement
menacés dans leur intégrité physique
autrement dit les hommes sont dans un
état d'insécurité permanente et c'est
vrai que si aucune loi ne me protège de
la prédation du plus fort bien je suis
constamment menacés survie est
constamment menacée et je ne peux pas
vivre comme ça je ne peux pas vivre
comme ça même si je fais partie
d'efforts parce que d'abord le fort et
toujours le faible d'un plus fort mais
aussi parce que la force
ne garantit pas nécessairement à survie
si les hommes ont inventé des armes
c'est précisément pour compenser les
inégalités de force comme j'ai pu lire
récemment en commentaire l'effort était
supérieure aux faibles et un jour samuel
colt les a remis à égalité donc la force
physique ne nous prémunit pas contre la
prédation et puis il ya d'autres moyens
les coalitions et trahisons et piège
toutes les stratégies que l'on peut
inventer pour attenter à la vie du plus
fort montre que même le plus fort est en
danger et donc les hommes qui vivent
dans cet état de nature ou rien de les
prémunit contre la violence des autres
ou à chaque instant leur vie est menacée
vont alors éprouver une passion qui va
l'emporter en intensité sur toutes les
autres passions et cette passion c'est
la peur de la mort violente
les hommes vont prendre conscience du
caractère contre-productif de la
violence égoïste pour s'apercevoir que
cette violence se retourne contre elle
même et comme chacun sait qui vit par
l'épée périra par l'épée
plus on a des demies plus on a de chance
de subir une mort violente
donc prenons conscience que la guerre de
tous contre tous ne peut conduire qu'à
la mort de tous les hommes décidèrent de
poser les armes décidèrent de mettre fin
à la guerre de tous contre tous ils
décidèrent au nom de leurs intérêts de
renoncer à leurs intérêts au nom de leur
intérêt vital collectif de renoncer à
leurs intérêts privés
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
chez obs c'est une passion qui rend les
hommes raisonnables
la peur est une passion mais c'est cette
passion là qui va permettre de basculer
dans la raison qui va permettre de ne
plus se comporter comme des animaux la
peur des hommes les a forcés à prendre
du recul par rapport à leurs intérêts
privés et à se dire que tout bien
considéré tout bien calculé ça n'en vaut
pas la peine
c'est contre productif ça n'en vaut pas
la peine parce qu en se comportant de
manière prédatrice et violente augmente
plus qu'autre chose le risque de subir
nous mêmes la violence et la prédation
les hommes finissent par se rendre
compte que leur violence se retourne
contre eux et donc c'est ça qui va
mettre un terme à la guerre de tous
contre tous c'est ça
va donner lieu à scops appelle le pacte
social alors n'oublions pas que ops est
un théoricien du contractualisme
contractualisme s'éviter que création de
l'état c'est le résultat d'un contrat
contrat passé entre les hommes alors un
contrat tacite pas forcément un contrat
formulée mais en tout cas un accord
passé entre les hommes pour créer une
situation qui soit mutuellement
avantageuse
c'est ça le principe du contrat c'est
que toutes les parties y trouvent leur
intérêt va pas signer un contrat qui va
contre nos intérêts et le contrat repose
sur la notion de consentement
donc si les hommes passent un contrat
entre eux c'est qu'ils le veulent c'est
qu'ils ont conscience que c'est dans
leur intérêt
donc c'est bien un pacte que passent les
hommes pour sortir de l'état de nature
et d'ailleurs le mot pacte il est issu
du latin pâques ce qui veut dire paix
donc le pacte c'est ce que l'on passe
pour faire la paix pour être en paix et
à travers ce pacte chacun renonce à
exercer sa puissance naturelle contre
l'autre la puissance naturelle c'est à
dire la puissance qui n'est pas encadrée
par les limites
la puissance qui n'est pas contenue par
des lois l'état de nature
c'est l'état de la puissance naturelle
du droit de nature et l'état social ce
sera l'état du droit civil du droit
civilisé donc elle est la condition pour
que ce pacte puissent être passés bien
c'est tout simplement que tous les
hommes en fasse de même que tous les
hommes renonce à exercer leur violence
bah oui sinon ça marche pas on va pas
dire allez-y alesi signé signé moi j'ai
pas signé anne on peut pas s'extraire du
pacte social c'est soit tout le monde
soit personnes donc il faut qu'il y ait
une sorte d'autorité qui garantissent
que chacun va obéir au pacte social que
c'était pas juste une signature sans
valeur façon que si vous signez un
contrat de ce contrat a une valeur parce
qu'il existe des juridictions les
juridictions qui sont en mesure de vous
faire payer le prix d'une désobéissance
aux contrats signature ça a du poids
mais ça n'a de poids que parce qu'il
existe une autorité qui sera en mesure
de lui donner du poids que parce qu'il
existe une autorité qui est capable
d'exercer sa force pour vous contraindre
à respecter le contrat
donc pour que ce pacte social est une
valeur il faut un garant qui possède la
force qui possède l'autorité et qui va
tirer les oreilles à celui qui aura
signé son bep ir et qui sera ce gars en
se garant ce sera l'état l'état c'est la
structure qui veillera à faire respecter
le contrat à faire respecter la loi à
faire respecter l'ordre civil
autrement dit la sécurité des individus
qui ayant signé le contrat social
deviennent des citoyens et qui publiera
tous ceux qui transgresseront l'ordre
civil donc à travers le pacte social
les individus se livrent à ce qu'on
appellera un transfert de souveraineté
c'est-à-dire un transfert de pouvoir ils
transfèrent leurs pouvoirs naturels
individuel le pouvoir de nuire à autrui
le pouvoir de prédation et le transfert
à l'état en échange de quoi l'état ne
garantit ma sécurité
et ça cette idée de transfert de
souveraineté
c'est l'idée que j'échange à l'état ma
liberté contre sa protection
je renonce à nuire aux autres je renonce
à leur voler ce qu'il possède à les
considérer comme des proies et en
contrepartie l'état me protège de la
prédation des autres voilà pourquoi pour
obs
il est important que le pouvoir de
l'état soit absolue autrement dit qu'ils
soient sans limite et c'est pourquoi
l'état devra avoir le monopole de la
violence légitime le monopole de la
violence légitime alors là encore on
pourrait y voir un oxymore violence
légitime
ça paraît difficile d'envisager une
violence qu'ils soient soutenus par le
droit et met justement cet oxymore a un
sens c'est précisément que la justice a
besoin de la force pour être respecté
comme je le disais tout à l'heure ce qui
confère du poids à une juridiction
c'est-à-dire un organisme de pouvoir
c'est le fait qu'ils soient détenteurs
d'une force une force coercitive ski
décision d'un juge a un poids c'est pas
le juge c'est pas le juge avec sa robe
et son ailleurs en bois parce que c'est
pas lui qui va vous emmener en prison le
juge représente la justice mais il n'est
pas la force de la justice la force de
la justice ce sont les policiers
la corporation chargée d'appliquer la
force publique
et c'est parce que la justice possède
l'appui de la force publique
elle possède son bras armée qu'elle peut
être respecté et qu'elle peut faire
figure d'autorité
on se rappelle de la citation de pascal
la justice sans la force est impuissante
la force sans la justice est tyrannique
exercer la force sans que celle ci ne
soit juste c'est le propre des tyrans
c'est aussi le propre des hommes à
l'état de nature mais une justice qui
n'a pas de force
c'est une justice qui est condamné à ne
jamais pouvoir être appliquées
c'est une justice qui ne sera jamais
respecté et donc à ce moment là la
justice n'est plus qu'un concept n'est
plus qu'un voeu pieux
elle ne sert plus à rien la justice
n'est pas la justice sans une
effectivité qui lui est donnée par les
moyens de se faire respecter
voilà pourquoi l'état détient le
monopole de la violence légitime et qui
citoyens ne doivent une obéissance
absolue
n'oublions pas que la crainte est la
plus puissante des passions et si c'est
la plus puissante des passions si c'est
elle qui a tiré les hommes de l'état de
nature pour leur faire fondé l'ordre
civil
si c'est cette crainte qui est le plus
puissant levier d'influencé sur le
comportement humain
il faut que l'état aspire la crainte aux
individus la métaphore du léviathan est
là pour nous le rappeler sur terre nul
n'est son maître c'est une définition
qui correspond d'ailleurs également à
satan le mètre d'ici bas et c'est ça
selon oops
la clé de l'ordre politique alors
pourquoi
sur cette vidéo je me permettrai une
ouverture sur la modernité à savoir
qu'aujourd'hui dans le modèle politique
qui est actuellement le nôtre les choses
ont évolué les principes et les leviers
du pouvoir se sont métamorphosés alors
certes l'état détient toujours la force
et il ne se prive pas utilisée pour
réprimer la contestation
donc la force est toujours un moyen
d'exercice du pouvoir
mais aujourd'hui l'état utilise
également une autre arme c'est la
division la division n'a pas besoin de
passer par la force
la division ça relève de la stratégie
ça relève de l'ingénierie sociale
la division c'est ce qu'on obtient
chaque jour d'élection sommes sommés
d'aller nous exprimer sur notre vision
politique en fonction d'un parti par
définition un parti c'est une partie la
partie qui fragmentent le tout la partie
qui divise le tout il est certain que
dans un système électorale multipartite
nous avons le choix du parti pour lequel
nous votons nous avons liberté plus
grande que dans les régimes on n'existe
qu'à un parti unique et pour peu que les
différents partis partagent conception
commune
une conception qui soit fondamentalement
la même bien ce moment là notre choix
devient une illusion il devient un
mensonge est un piège
la division
on sait ce qui fait que deux personnes
partageant les mêmes conditions
d'existence partageant mêmes principes
mêmes valeurs fondamentales vont c# et
quand elles vont parler politique c'est
ce qui fait que quand on apprécie
quelqu'un pour ce qu'il est pour ce
qu'il fait on va se mettre à ne plus
apprécier si on apprend qu'il met un
autre bulletin que le nôtre dans l'urne
la guerre de tous contre tous peut aussi
avoir cette forme-là la guerre des
opinions politiques
la guerre qui oppose les pour et les
contre et rouges et les bleus et
peut-être que si nous sommes sortis de
l'état de nature d'un état de guerre de
tous contre tous c'est peut-être pour
mieux replonger dans une autre guerre de
tous contre tous la guerre des ego la
guerre des étiquettes la guerre des
espoirs lorsque les hommes sont sortis
de l'état de nature
ils ont cessé d'être naïfs ils ont eu
une prise de conscience au fond c'est
peut-être
la condition pour sortir de notre état
de nature actuelle de l'état de nature
moderne prendre conscience je vous
remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]